one year ago
on this very day december 1st the
symptoms of the new coronavirus were
first detected in wuhan china
that's according to a published study
cbs news was the first u.s network to go
to wuhan before the city went into
lockdown in january i remember that
raymie andosencio just returned to show
us what life is like now
in the area where those first covet
cases were discovered
in this city of 11 million the world's
first epicenter of coronavirus
harsh lockdowns have given way to a
hardcore nightlife
at wuhan's central market a food vendor
tells us business is back and he's proud
and happy
that sense of optimism is shared by
students coming to see this massive new
government sanctioned exhibition
called people first lives first in the
same space as one of the earliest
biggest makeshift coveted hospitals it
hails
president xi jinping as heroic and the
strong leadership of china's communist
party
it also highlights frontline healthcare
workers but mentions of those who died
are hard to find attendees told us it
was factual
and comprehensive beijing having
declared victory in its war on kovid
has now opened new fronts trying to pin
its origin on other countries
including the u.s italy and india
although china was the first to report
cases
said foreign ministry spokesman jolie
jen just last week it doesn't
necessarily mean that the virus
originated in china
this is the wuhan institute of virology
believed by some to be the origin of
kovid 19. now we tried to get access to
this institute for months but we were
turned down
we also tried to interview many chinese
doctors across the country
they all said they were either busy or
were frankly barred from speaking with
us
we did speak with dr lin pha wong who's
been researching kovit's origin
what's the chance that the coronavirus
did not
originate in china origination is
difficult but let's face it a human
outbreak started in gohan
who works at a state-owned enterprise is
one of countless people still
looking for answers his father died from
kovid in february
the government sent condolences and
about 600 dollars as compensation
it felt hollow he said i still don't
know where the virus came from
if you ask me who to blame i don't know
and here we are again in wuhan outside
the city's first
hospital to receive coronavirus patients
dr wong says there are now
three major knowledge gaps we have to
fill in in order to beat this virus
one of course is covet's origin two is
why some patients take so long to
recover
and three how long antibodies can really
protect us
tony all right raymond asensio in wuhan
china for us remy thank you very much
he's been pioneering the coverage there
with the first network
and now he continues it those are other
big questions remaining though the ones
you pointed out at the end yeah
but we could learn so many lessons from
what they've been through i mean
what the experts agree on uniformly is
about mask
and everybody seems to have gotten that
message i think
except with the exception of the united
states we can and should do better i
like what they said
people people first lives first we are
unique and wonderful people
yes we are i love us
i love it i love us it's a great country
come visit sometimes sometimes we got
issues
i love us